[Music]
what's the most exotic meat you you
dudes have tried i know you guys are
professionals exotically i've tried
whale and horse i tried whale whale's
pretty good i didn't like i got like
whale sushi and then it was uh
kind of irony
and it just uh so i had the the texture
of fish which is very bloody and irony
at least the one that i got i don't know
if it was mine tasted like um
a rare uh filet mignon is it in the form
of a steak it looks like steak mine was
nigerian milo's nigerian yeah same same
but mine had the whale steak that was
cooked like a steak oh was that good it
feels everything is exactly like steak
but then it tastes like fish it's really
weird it fits with your mind yeah it
does it but was yours purple because
this like the meat to me
mine was like kind of purple
it was like purple but it was still it
was still like steak ish yeah like red
red purple yeah and then the horse i had
you could if you didn't say it's horse
you can't even tell it just looks like
beefy it tastes like beef but it tastes
juicier and leaner and then has it's
like slightly gamey i thought it was
sweeter a little bit
i had a [ __ ] pig's head lately i saw
you guys off camera yesterday yeah so
like we went to this
bougie restaurant in vegas and like they
brought out a [ __ ] pig's head and it
was like super [ __ ] visceral and [ __ ]
just the head
just the head and like then they like
cut the ears off and then oh shutting
off the cheek and [ __ ] and like ginsu
what kind of restaurant was this like it
was like a booze you wanted this area 15
or 51 place oh it's in there yeah it's
in there whoa it's like under underneath
it or something it's like you have to go
downstairs and it's like under are you
like oh what the hell yeah uh it sounds
like
my neighbors wanted to go and i was i
was just down and then we got there and
we're both i mean nikki doesn't even eat
meat so she was just like watching
[Laughter]
and then uh
so yeah but then i tried the pig uh
cheek and it was you know it tasted like
pork pig cheeks are good though it was
good but it definitely you know i don't
know about you guys but i felt a little
bit guilty about it like seeing all that
[ __ ] happen like did you feel guilty
about eating whale no no
in japan yeah so like when i'm in
another country i'm just like i kind of
like just like submit to whatever the
country does
so i was just like oh this this is
normal for them so i'm just trying
whatever they do daily same i was in
norway eating the whale which
it seemed regular so i was like oh i'm
trying their cultural thing versus like
yo this is hella wrong everywhere else
you know what i mean yeah for sure i
don't attach morality to taste well some
people do so there's a lab-grown meat
company
now that's immoral primeval foods and
they're planning on bringing a whole
host of exotic meats to the market
including zebra
lion
elephant and tiger and it's all lab
grown all lab grown why do they want to
grow those meats people want them but
they don't want the ethical
responsibility behind it but what
happens if like i eat lab-grown tiger
and i'm like man this is the best meat
i've ever had now i want real tigers
yeah what does real taste like i don't
think they're counting on that guys i
think they're i think i i think they're
counting on you guys going let's eat
this more it's like for people that
already eat it so it's almost like
creating a
a a sex doll for pedal top pedophiles or
something
can't they just make sure that they're
successful at the i don't know the
lab-grown chicken and and fish and like
beef first and make sure that
everybody's really good people are they
do have lab grown beef yeah but it's
like fully acceptable you know oh like
make it a home run first yeah
before jumping to exotic animals like
elephant and [ __ ] i think these guys
want to get want to get their niche
market because everyone a lot of people
places are working but trying to do that
they're they're trying to be the toro of
impossible burger you know
you ever had zebra before no who's
chasing for that though you know
zebra like in zimbabwe or something i
don't know people want to try weird
whatever
hipsters want to try that right yes
exactly you okay dude
this one getting to you
allergy attacking my eye or something
that's why i said do you want to wait to
film are you good i'm good you said
you're good stop being a [ __ ] on camera
please
would you guys eat elephant
i thought you said elf real elephant
would you eat mouth or they don't look
tasty ethically sourced lab grown i
would i would eat everything except dog
yeah i would eat dog too you'd eat dog
why were you everything period yeah
that's true it just depends on the
scenario like i'm not gonna go like uh
like let's say go looking for a dog in
america but if a dog was trying to eat
you then that's your only choice to buy
them back no like if i was like uh i
don't know in some country where that's
normal and then they have you like
perfectly raised
yeah they're like ethnically raised
whatever i would try it
but i wouldn't like seek it out you know
you know what's funny an ethically
raised dog is a regular dog what about a
coyote
would you eat a coyote i would have a
good boy salad
cheese like with elephant if uh
if they didn't kill the elephant for me
and they already killed it just sliced
it and then they're like ding dong come
on over i'm like oh i guess i'll try
some elephant because you know we used
to eat like [ __ ] woolly mammoths that
was like a pretty big thing for humans
well when you said we i was like when
well some scientists had wanted a couple
back in the day yeah
they found the mammoth intact in the ice
and they like heated up part of it and
they all tried it and they said it
tastes like [ __ ]
i think with like things like a dog or a
cat that we've already built
domesticated relationships with there's
like definitely that emotional weirdness
but like um
things like elephant which obviously i
haven't had like a one-on-one
relationship with one it's definitely a
degree removed i don't see another dog
that's nyc my dog though jesus part when
i see another dog you just don't be
looking at my my dog i get hungry around
to the dog
that dog looks like the dog is my family
and then the other dog is somebody
else's family that you're going to eat
everybody bring their dog around
be a rib eye steak bart tries to [ __ ]
order their dogs
so you can eat the doodle with noodles
you would go eat at the at that
restaurant at the top of the protector
with tony john
what are some animals you guys find cute
but you still eat the [ __ ] out of this
baby chick i guess
we don't eat it as a baby well in a
balloon i guess
we need chicken nuggets probably i think
ostriches are disgusting creatures and
they should be yeah i agree peacocks i
eat the [ __ ] out of a pizza oh yeah i
need a peacock imaginable uh ostrich egg
omelette look how big that thing is that
seems gross though there's too much egg
i think yeah too much yolk i could make
a pizza the ratio is a little heavy yeah
a lot of things i feel like ducks are
cute as [ __ ] but i can't resist eating
the [ __ ] ducks are delicious they're so
cute i know oh like frog is really good
oh see i like frogs too i feel weird
about eating frogs though it's ugly dude
i feel weird about eating like because
just looking like a frog leg yeah
you know what surprisingly good was live
octopus i was shocked man i was like
that [ __ ] looks so garbage man that [ __ ]
looks like [ __ ] hentai porn right
it's weird though when you like put it
in your mouth but it's still like such
wrapping your lips yeah but you're just
like oh you know what this this is like
taiwanese cartilage [ __ ] you know have
you done that no i haven't but i was
just thinking like every animal on the
planet right whether it's aquatic or
mammal like
some culture eats that thing right or
has in the past they have to survive
often right so there's there's a way to
respect eating anything because you just
think of the people that this is their
culture yeah but if a new animal got
discovered or just recently came out
would you be curious and want to eat it
and be one of the first as long as it's
not in the pixar movie yet yeah yeah
it's not my first instinct to be like oh
i want to eat that [ __ ] but it's
like a [ __ ] eyeball guy from monsters
i need the [ __ ] out mike what's
cute so we originally discovered these
eyeball guys
i have no curiosity for eating monkey
too close to human i like them too i
like them too much they're my favorite
animal in the whole world i enjoy
monkeys that's really your favorite
animal oh yeah what kind of monkey any
kind of chimpanzee dude i [ __ ] love
chimpanzees so you would never eat a
chimp head never
i would cry i remember watching this
dude he went into the jungle and like he
went hunting with his tribe and then
they got like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] toucan sam they got like
whatever they got this monkey right and
then
they made this big pile of fire and they
were cooking them and they're like
because you are the guest you could have
anyone do you want you know and they're
like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] maybe i'll i'll get
this like ant eater or something or
they're like a like a chicken looking
bird you know they're like and then all
the dudes were clowning them like you
didn't pick the monkey this [ __ ]
idiot dude because the monkey's the most
delicious one that's probably like one
of the best ones you clowned about that
yeah you didn't eat the monkey [ __ ]
idiot
got the bird you know
if i if someone made fun of me like that
i'll be like man [ __ ] you i'm telling
you the monkey then
just don't make fun of me like bart i
think i'm i'm very open to like trying
things uh from whether it be a cultural
experience to just in general just like
the uh one
try everything once you know what i mean
would you eat not a he not a human but
the um operationally extracted tumor of
a human why would you eat their garbage
still meat i would well if
if like a village that had like survived
like so much [ __ ] and said that actually
eating that has some other
spiritual or blah blah blah thing then
maybe like it has to be tied to
something of like why can't it just be
for taste it's the guy who has like
gigantism on his balls oh yeah
elephantitis yeah dude bart this whole
video is [ __ ] amazing
bart would you try a newborn no way okay
we found the [ __ ] line we found but a
senior citizen he'll eat the [ __ ] out of
because i was thinking about monkeys too
and i'm like dude i don't know so
because i put myself in a situation
let's say i'm stranded on the island
right and then um i'm hungry as [ __ ]
that's that's not fair you need anything
and then i made a spear and i let's say
i've been alone for a whole week
and then i finally see my first meet
which is a monkey and it's curious
george bro
i'm like do i do i now make friends with
it so that so we have a buddy for the
for my rest of my life i love her or do
i kill him i think he'll befriend him
first because if he can survive you
could probably eat the stuff easy you
just gotta follow him help you find food
so i don't think i would eat monkeys but
i will also say
anything in survival mode is [ __ ]
game on fair game because like at the
end of other humans in survival have
been able to like cannibalize in order
for survival and it's just like that is
what it is
like i think you would eat a you throw a
spear out of baby
you're on an island and then you need to
what do i need to throw a spirit of baby
for
it's a wild baby though they could kill
a baby much easier yeah it could be it
could be one of those baby geniuses yeah
they're swinging
it might end up on one of those girders
you know in new york if it's a baby
genius i'm going to end up slipping and
falling and tripping and getting tied up
somehow it could be a look who's talking
baby
it's stewie so showing the event of like
you were on an airline commercial flight
that crash and then they're all deciding
who to eat like the soccer team in
[ __ ] brazil yeah and some lady had a
newborn that was kind of like you know
obviously not gonna survive you would
choose you'd select that as the first i
wouldn't eat it until the mom was
willing to eat it
i would [ __ ] ditch that crew
and wait for them to [ __ ]
implode and kill each other
i'm gonna pretend to be as noble as
possible in that situation it's kind of
like if there's a baby a [ __ ] woman
and then myself it's like [ __ ] dude like
it's always women and children should
survive first right so it's like yo well
i thought you could turn to the stepdad
yeah that would be a good move
that's honestly the right move that's
the walking dead move that's where you
go that's the right answer and then try
to gain custody then eat the bigger boys
away so i'm eating my own so it's not
really like murder do you just guess
later i mean i'd look for a banana
before that but
or or can you imagine
what if you felt what if you saw that
later after you ate the baby oh [ __ ]
banana tree oh god but i hate bananas
what hotel buffet's right there thanks
to syntax though if if you are going to
be the first guy to pitch cannibalism
you can just be like all right let's eat
that chick right there and then
everyone's like yo that's [ __ ] up and
i'll start my inner [ __ ]
[Laughter]
can't use that joke again
[Music]
you
[Music]